quite impressive
welcome everybody to play though people
with more dentists than you can handle
we have GM Dennis Boros along with
myself December 20th
Friday action Quad Squad to champion
Dennis LaRue it's a pleasure for me to
be here thank you for joining me
yep and we're gonna play yeah we should
I think make sense you want to let them
know what time controls you want to play
or anything am i don't have preferences
not zero plus one no zero plus zero plus
no call it that's for the children yes
exactly
okay I'd still only rated we will only
be accepting rated challenger rating
points yes dear viewers what else I
think that's it start challenging us and
we'll start playing you and by we I mean
Grandmaster Dennis Boris right now we
only have five challenges I don't think
that's enough right yeah you were
telling me before we went live that you
would not you weren't convinced that
we're alive he probably doesn't even
believe that we're live live streaming
now I always see five dollars-six okay
so your perception altered I don't know
anyway it's that's in within the
statistical probability that it's near
to too close to five 700 700 we're on
the threshold of reality yeah of this
becoming a real stream help us out
viewers if you're watching challenge us
oh the grandmasters motivation because
it he doesn't believe this Wow okay
thank you test 1199 clever can crash
chest remote EB where are you chest
where mo TV he's not
five-oh five-oh 3:05 5 I don't think
I've I don't think we're going I don't
even yeah I yes I believe you believe I
believe I don't believe in miracles I
believe in people I don't believe in
miracle well people are watching the
street they can do oh he's not gonna
start playing until we get to 10 I think
is the point here as according to that
number you're at seven we're three yeah
we are three challenges away yeah for
like I'm getting eight this is a rare
opportunity people grandmasters do not
grow on trees you don't get to play them
all the time nine go I'm getting more
and more convinced that we alive little
less convinced a little less coming up
we're back to the threat oh wow
all right there so we we believed in you
yeah you proved us right 11 oh it's too
real no I think I give you the chance to
choose casual what's casual chest by the
way what is there such a thing I don't
think it has any meaning to it
Jess is not such a it's not a casual
game you're always out from blood memory
play chess you're serious
it's a serious business looking yeah
yeah yeah where is a good chance we're
building we're building the suspense and
building the suspense and now issue well
it's how grandmasters play chess dude
they don't just like start exchanging
everything in the center they let the
tension build let it build the amour
kill Asafa call about playing come on
unless casual okay we're learning lots
of things viewers chess is not a casual
game
I don't know Jules sounds like a cool
name
I think we're starting all right before
probably not a bad move according to
Fisher but who knows maybe it is it's
aggressive that's Gracie 593 a six so
there's no Bishop b5 funny business
ah you're already too strong yet yeah oh
my god you're back in neither territory
Bishop d3 what is that Bishop d7 what's
me well it's more normal there Bishop
but it should please be anything I
should be three or well it's kind of
blocking the view over the night that's
why it's kind of feels a little strange
ngo5 asking where this Pony is going 92
b3 yeah let's just develop I can't
really hurt that badly and eventually
why would want an ID five jumps mm-hmm
well that's not gonna happen if the
bishop is in the way right yeah this is
hmm that Bishop is poorly placed your
bishop does not belong on d3 probably
well going to threaten ideas of B for
putting pressure on that d4 pawn now
Bishop d3 is not a bad mood per se but
it's very rare is this normal
no f4 is not that normal dark sport his
dark squares are falling apart now kind
of you're not gonna take it I could but
I'm not I'm not convinced I have to
let's just play this funny little move
put any pressure on this guy me four
have this before I do it - and that's
five looks like it's strong but it not
it's just a shot in the dark
is that a song I shot in the dark no it
sounds like a do something doesn't it
might be might be you tell us viewer and
where's the chat I should be am I
supposed to be model I think chat should
tell us if that's a real do song or we
just messed it up 95 interesting they
can really take because there's Bishop
age 7 and Dan Dan the Queen can't
capture no so you don't take on d5 I
yeah you could I could I could probably
I'm just gonna develop its ozzy osbourne
okay thank you thank you
so the real expert Bensimon que andan
told us it's Ozzy Ozzy Osbourne shot in
the dark
yes now we need the melody yeah we need
the melody can anyone post it in chat
the melody you know they should test
themselves chess is demanding and so
does music so as music and expressing it
in chat forums yeah so my C C class
analysis tells me that the Grandmaster
is gonna win but lost my bishop there
yeah yeah five black is black is better
yeah the bishop does it well now the D
file really doesn't belong to him at all
in you have d5 which I've been told is
the strategic point in these structures
where you have your pawn on e5 and
especially the biggest problem that this
Bishop on d3 is fairly passive mm-hmm
and the e3 Bishop is loose that's kind
of
main issue I could take here or just
capture it back
let's just take this pong let's be
greedy okay
yeah is it with the idea of we're trying
to take on e5 later and this pawn had no
defenses under if I take the pawn that
had more defenders this will be an easy
prey on e5 I like it make sense to me
like me for the Wild Hunt I don't
understand I Begley Seri Wild Hunt what
is that referring to that is referring
to davechowie Witcher I'll getcha point
to your richard dawson point to your mid
chuck well so if you're using your your
telepathy yes what do you think chad is
saying right now um I don't have you
seen night fliers on Netflix open up
YouTube I'm doing it I heard of it but
I've never seen an episode of night
fliers but probably you're right
everyone should be talking about night
players and right edges well no it's
just what you heat telepathy is a plot
element in this show that's all
toss up pong for your Witcher then push
it to f5 oh my goodness
that was a nice remix I tried my best
Wow rook wants to eat one right let's
push it
so far I'm happy because as heartless as
a chess player could be I love pawns if
I can push them even more I mean getting
even more happier ah sneak sneaky sneaky
stuff is going on which I don't
appreciate
shame easily avoided with something yeah
I just put your rook on the white square
and then there's no bishop see simple
life is simple but we always want to
complicate it right why is that I know
you just think that life is boring
otherwise oh I will accept that analysis
okay I mean think if you guys are
getting crazy in the chat room
get ready still it's going to the
defender use that five pawn and get my
knight ready
whoa is the attack don't even go Knights
see for harassing like jewels
I don't like the way you play because
you're trying to stop me some things
that I want to do
rook the one okay I shall push look okay
chat room
I shall push again and then the tag wrap
pulling on h3
rook F - okay okay that's act we don't
have yeah we don't have a rating minimum
for you but we are likely going to pick
the higher rated players so our minimum
is 2700 plus okay that's the minimum and
if you have less
five dollars and we'll consider playing
you exactly or courtesy of Dennis Larew
and his choice if he decided it's okay
then you might challenge me oh we've got
18 challenges now I'm convinced for your
life
yeah it's someone else yeah well yeah
matrix maze matrix referring yeah to our
little thought experiment or a little
philosophical diversion earlier about
whether or not we were actually
experiencing reality said I don't know
if this is live put your shoe on your
head and then someone says share
believes and someone else answered our
question about a shot in the dark
confirmed by Ben Simon and Aussie song
from the 80s and that's it more or less
okay talk to us how many do we have here
Oh almost a hundred mm something's
happening production there we go so it
should be your discretion choose one
place okay oh wow look at all those
arrows I want to see let's give all that
we I don't recognize I don't recognize
any of these well because their
nicknames they're fake oh I thought I
was looking that makes a lot more sense
right oh let's play this guy on the
lifeguard guy yeah sounds cool
good luck lifeguard let's see what so
let me ask Chet what should I play here
Chet okay play the low-rated first it
will go faster okay we're Dennis what do
you think about tomorrow's tournament
chat you better tell us what to play
against e4 before yeah you got to tell
me what we doing I mean I'm sorry have
oh yeah where they uh yeah how involved
are you chat come on what do you play
again ninety-four
I mean I'll start with night absolutely
and you're too professional no Knight f6
is fine they can still tell me what to
do
you can't answer d4 with E for ya that's
highly illegal okay
someone suggested that England beyond
England is actually misspelled it's
actually a Connor right alright we've
had three illegal illegal suggestions
and finally someone gave a legal
suggestion d5 semi Slav Oh 96 was
another good one benoni is another one
okay sign is another Knight f6 all right
good job
Thank You Chad alright so Ben and Oni it
is Benoni it is okay
lifeguard you're going down lifeguards
saved my life because I'll be struggling
so the only thing you need to know about
dis opening and it's not that good you
have less space but if you can trick
your opponent it's fine
is that lifelike who is your opponent in
life entropy other humans both just
trying to take that pawn so it is a
proper benoni oh this is it yeah just
putting my king into safe there try this
but but when I yeah this is a funky way
of playing it but it is still a Bonomi
I shall take that pump
what's more common and said is he he
takes is always done though they almost
always play ecigs
yeah I'll check first mmm OD 697
and probably we're playing alongside the
tall's way of playing Todd used to play
the system and then just recently the
guy named Carlson picked it up I think
I've heard of him he plays this way too
now yeah so this time I feel it's time
to sacrifice Wow but Wow okay but not oh
this is like this is a proper sacrifice
yeah I don't think of it this time to
talk with him I don't put this in my
talk my box of tall like sacrifices and
like the trophy and like yeah in the
exchange yeah yeah it is so now I have
the bishop fair nothing to do with that
pawn was an accident
but also these bishops are pretty
muscular I like that
adjective Queen h4 on her ass harassment
in the workplace bad harassment on the
chess board good good okay mmm I'm
tempted to take pawns but how about
checkmating I guess that's like the
better way of doing stuff g3 I'm not not
appreciating that vibe just pre-move g3
that's rude I think that's wrong you
shouldn't pre move when you're facing a
grandmaster
you should get intimidated right yeah
they should fear you yes
proper healthy fear yes g3 removed don't
do that no sense of danger I mean
Knight c3 bringing that pony back for
defense and he wants to go to you for
yeah
I'm gonna activate my bishop then go f5
and after and if Knight 94 here I just
go drop back and dangle f5 this is a
closed position the exchange doesn't
matter as much so yes yes I'm down in
exchange but I have nice little piece
play okay five
getting my queen 2g5 back I'm chasing
this night away
hmm hmm jet sounds awfully quiet well
they're asking
they are asking what your opinion is on
tomorrow's tourney now what is
tomorrow's tourney
yeah be more specific I mean which
attorney are you talking about the
ping-pong tourney I think they don't
know about it yet oh we love Forks right
you don't find on people who Fork we do
not okay good that's hoping that's fine
it is acceptable in my accept oh okay
what's wrong hey guys what's wrong
because the show is lacking some
excitement excitement we need more
emotions okay okay all right matter
chance here we go man
Chet you've got to help us well help us
out I mean okay so here maybe this will
spice it up someone in the chat said wow
this guy has such a huge ego now I don't
know they must be talking about me I'm
quite the narcissist yes I don't think
so
the ping-pong tourney and then yet the
other thread of conversation was the
tourney they're talking about the
ping-pong you don't think yeah I think
it's okay you know to have high you go
otherwise how would you win the
ping-pong tourney you want more
excitement in this Tony Chen and I think
Tony Chan is very excited about that
well he's actually our biggest detractor
today who's someone's speaking to you in
Mugsy ah okay or maybe they're not I
don't know what I'm doing there I think
if my Hungarian is good then the person
is asking which one is me oh and I think
we'll let them figure it out I think
that's a difficult question well
[Laughter]
is this exciting for you enough this is
interactive entertainment okay we don't
do all the work for you
or we just will that's Grandmaster Denis
Boros um so far we're trying to check me
the bottle mr. X I yeah one left or two
right I don't know it's all a matter of
perspective man throw in some lower
rated players okay well we gotta we
gotta finish this game this is a nice
looking game yeah you guys appreciate
chess we're enjoying this yeah are you
enjoying our time I'm having a blast I
don't know but I think you want me to
talk louder in a in a slightly more
excited cadence yeah we this won't
irritate you too much I think we just
want oh yeah checkmate I think 0 1 means
Mike 1 and I think we can move on to the
next game
I hope Tony Chen is excited to hear that
hmm so many new people to play you're
actually at 20 challenges which is sweet
oh wow it's real it's real realer than
real and yeah so they won't come kick me
out as long as I just keep and I heard
he being in a super nervous and excited
voice what I heard that I can play
evelin's modified dog I'm not sure about
accepting such experiments but I'm
willing to play the owner well I mean
they don't state the nature of said
modification that is putting a collar on
your dog is modifying it on some level
is it that it's true that it's Jeff
we got a smile
we got a smile from the tough audience
guys okay and we're almost out of
hundred nope okay and I'm gonna keep
talking speaking louder and louder cuz
we need excitement so what's the
difference between being excited and
being a little bit dizzy
I'm just curious I I don't know or I
don't know you don't know well I don't
know either
yeah some people just need they have a
sensationalist a taste for
sensationalism they don't like quiet
subtlety I don't like subtle people
they're not into it you think Freud was
shouting on his spare time you could
have been I don't I didn't know the guy
yeah I think I'm gonna capture that
probably yeah because he's giving it to
you that Queen is just everybody is
blocking the way so I'm curious
it could be Evelyn that I'm blamed or
because or the dog or the dog or my
modification is that they've merged into
one may use some now and the important
question for you and for you chat have
you ever played against a lady or girl
named Evelyn a chess game that is I'm
not interested in your tennis matches
I'll let the chat answer that hope for
more competitive games stop dodging me
eh no name-calling Dennis oh there's
another Dennis hey man
fellow Dennis's we got to stick together
don't ah so we have three we're dodging
apparently yeah we're being accused of
dodging and cowards okay I am NOT a
coward I'm an exciting or excited brave
person I remember both you guys from
good luxuries this ain't another song
yeah hello chess people can you play
with your glasses off god I loved I
liked the one about Baltic gambit you
did something on the Baltic gambit uh
yeah but I'm not sure it's Baltic I
thought it's Portuguese Portuguese and
you know if I would want to visit a
country it would be Portugal and not the
Baltic one because it's cold there
someone's on your team for tomorrow oh
yeah yes because Sarnia oh well it's not
that are you guys really playing a pink
bomb during the minute I thought this is
a joke now I think it's a secret oh whoa
so whoever knows about the ping pong one
you know when it's half
got it and if you're not invited you're
entitled to Rach Rach Rach the st. Louis
Chess Club does not condone or encourage
rage in any form way shape or form okay
that's fair enough that's fair enough
so yeah in fact because me and Ilya and
there's an igloo stream time to time so
we have a chess feed team you do yeah I
am aware of this I am aware so if you're
high rated on the chess please join us
because you're rallying a team and if
you're low rated don't even know if
you're low rated you can say hey good
luck okay
cheer all right and you know just call
your higher rated friends and see how
you want to join if they want to play
got it you know that's a good told you
guys are in the know now and I think
that's a good way of starting
conversation that you act so hey you
haven't talked for like two years but
have you heard that Ilya and Dennis is
building a chess game yeah now are you
guys chess weebs or going to be the name
exact they're asking 1441 Q is asking is
Dennis is Dennis chess weep I think
you're missing a preposition there or
article rather a chess week I mean is
the name of the team so he is yes all
right
just making sure because he looks
familiar well you know what your memory
is working okay it's working well it's a
working memory and yeah just let's talk
a little bit about chess um I have the
two bishops so hooray also it's an extra
bishop hooray again and also I'm almost
meaning I just need to bring the lady
over there
and it's gonna be mate hey man that's a
mad dog if I'm playing the dog because
they're trying to make me I thought I'm
here to win not to not to get made it
when eight it usually means you don't
win so this is one thing that I always
tell everybody who doesn't play chess or
don't want to play chess castle safety
first mate later Newcastle you like
castling there I may or may not have a
co-worker who is who has expressed her
difficulty in believing in castle ink
ah so I'd like to approach the question
in this way do I believe in castling
that's true I don't know so like she
doesn't believe in it like she doesn't
believe in purpose or for those of you
who don't know what the Krampus is it's
no kind of like a little imp like
creature yes yes that tries to ruin your
Christmas own it's actually German isn't
it your best Krampus yes yeah yeah I am
yeah it's German its German yes oh the
King pawn now so we're up a billion
pieces and I say billion that's three
and probably I'm gonna bring my rook
over here and attack just for the fun
fun of it
hmm
man it's so interesting like have you
ever thought of like improving whisper
games in general well are you good at
this burg aims whisper game mystery game
I don't know what they are or whatever
whoever do I really want to know you
don't even want to know man I thought
like as someone who's well-versed and
philosophy would be interested in this
stuff no man I thought of every tell me
what it is so whisper game is whenever
you have lots of people around you and
you see two guys or girls suddenly start
whispering now some people can't whisper
properly they don't know that I was
always told that whispering does not
make friends live in you a whisper you
know you're not trying to make friends
we're trying to make you just trying to
distance from others right if you want
to make friends you're really loud and
excited oh yeah I forgot that was
supposed to be what I was doing right
yeah that's the way you make friends you
make eye contact or do all your friends
really excitable and loud yeah yeah I
mean I don't like them know that that's
what they do
what can you think you know do you tell
them they men's don't lower your voice
stop shouting at me but then be pleased
or my friends well we're still friends
that's true but but you're quiet so
that's kind of a paradox I'm a universal
you're like oh you can't do positional
tactical loud quiet whatever
let's see play to win offer a draw
Wow look at all those challenges I think
it's your time to choose again cause I
decided to play the overall Evelyn's dog
the zeitgeist was they want yet because
they want okay they want they want
faster no that's turn
five-o standard is a bit long mm-hmm if
I can find mu well for you that's
probably not too high yeah yeah yeah 300
k play clever game crashed clean the
back okay
I'm gonna place a 5 because it's the
most exciting move anything else is bad
especially the French and now you're a
fret friend then you love the French I
think shame on that person like it I
have a friend who likes the French or at
least he claims to but that I've never
seen it
ya know I mean whenever you hear people
say that I love the French don't trust
them
this is I mean people pay pay money for
this ok you guys are just getting it for
free on the internet
alright don't trust people who play the
French is that the wisdom no don't trust
their love for difference ok often then
you see plays live or online and they
say oh wow I don't have space I can't
move but this opening is great though
I'm having such a great time so
wonderful you should play the French as
well you will have no space no concert
play and that Bishop to boot and you can
suffer eternally for 70 moves wouldn't
that be great oh I think you're giving
our technical director a bit of uh
giving him a challenge and staying alive
somebody might be dying back there I
mean life is tough like it's hard the
truth hurts someone usually say over and
over and over again
are you giving odds against lower rated
players yeah I'm talking to him while
he's playing those are your odds that
maybe you should call this I'll distract
him those you're on the other hand in
London oh it's so exciting so much
excitement I may or may not play the
London at times I'm not saying it's not
playable no I'm ashamed but I I thought
about it and thought that maybe playing
1.e4 and entering the dragon it's a
little bit more challenging and fun it's
entertaining at the very least yeah it's
fun more fun to watch from yeah
I think if you want to become an awesome
player you should play aggressively
excitingly like unnies do you though and
it's like the technical director is
shaking in his seat right now this is
all the complete well actually yeah I
would say that you would agree with you
but say that you have to study but if
you assumes you're not gonna study um
let's say you did he says play the
French and play the London exactly so if
you're lazy play the French and the
London and you're done
no more studying needed you're good
you're good
a13 okay you know what the world is not
full of handouts mr. wheat straw okay a
39-hundred player is gonna need a little
more than a Chad advantage all right
well I don't know what to tell you
and to be honest with you you have you
phased or played the Spanish in general
I'm either either color well so a short
answer no because when I and classical
rated games I will play the Italian okay
that's fair not and then I also agree
with you that brave people play c5
against e4 just everyone else plays
whatever else they play exactly but in
general I do feel that you could have so
much fun playing the Spanish so try it
out it's much more fun than the London
trust me okay so you start playing
Bishop b5 and then getting hurt when
they played the marshall gambit against
me that's what you want now hurt them
when they play the marshall against you
I don't know finally sounds like work um
you don't have to enter the marshal by
the way oh there are world yeah there
are ways to avoid it
well I'll take that now my bishop enters
okay as some diligent viewer in the chat
is reminding me to remind you
mm-hmm the viewing audience and you
mm-hmm
Dennis boros yeah the Swiss Miss Swiss a
four-round Swiss paired g25 d5 USCF duel
rated tournament will be put will be
played this weekend on Saturday the 11th
yeah registered before 10:30 10:45
registration is casual I see so many
casual games but if I wouldn't want to
play casual games I could play the
London are we going to see you get into
some move three Bishop b5 line
if you have white pieces you wash lower
rated higher rated I don't know I'm game
for any of them it occurred to me at
some point that we actually used to work
our way okay hop down okay I mean that
guys in history was asking the chat he
wants he wants to play but this is no no
no no no no schedule oh sorry sorry you
got to do it radio and everything no no
no casual casual just don't do it
you're not casual people have you come
back graded your game your game yeah we
are listening to your requests chat
we're playing the lower rated people
okay let's give this 13 18 rated okay
thank you a chance okay alright so yes
let's play e4 let's actually do whatever
I've been preaching oh and Adrian K is
not listening to the to the sir main
feature you think okay not French not
London so what do you suggest
come on banished and Sicilian is well
you would be there italiano
and guess what nope this is how the big
near endless Spanish land Oh finally
tengo mucho miedo yes okay I'm very
scared so if you are unfamiliar with
this position well all of the world
champions has played the Spanish and got
good but okay yeah okay
all right feel free to have an opinion
well no it's more of a question I made I
don't immediate d4 is not a mainline
this was early so black needed to chase
the traffic away right okay and this is
I think like the old Steinitz
way of playing with the black piece
these are black pieces yes so if you're
from the 1900s like early 1900s
1920s you should be familiar with this
setup with black but if you're not
probably you don't know the theory
so I guess Chet is like saying all be
converted the old one to play the
Spanish not with light there's a mix of
topics being addressed in the chat
Grandmaster Boros see Chad is nice I
want to take your point someone's
telling us that they speak Spanish in
Spanish that's a clever way to they're
all good yeah no they're saying that I
speak Spanish all right come on warm up
with a little more competitive game say
they've been asking us to play lower
rated players okay ooh someone will tell
the Magnus that he shouldn't play the
London poking a little fun at us okay
and what do you think about the Petrov
defense is it a defense or are you just
um you know if you don't feel like
playing go ahead and play the Petroff if
you like chess
don't play the Petroff yeah play the
Spanish or play the Spanish play the
civilian like I yeah
I've played Spanish for 15 years so I
want to change to something new now well
my recommendation is the Danish gambit
oh that's perfect yeah thank perfect
because it probably is the namesake for
both of us
yeah well I'm gonna start referring to
it as the Dennis gambit in the singing
of anybody that cares are notices yeah
they should they should alright let's
pick up pawns because so this yes so
this early d6 was wrong I don't remember
some Spanish theories I know yeah early
a6 often happens I know that the Berlin
starts with Knight f6 and yet allow me
five drop or whatever so lady I'll take
the lady free that's a for you lady
so I would be playing chess and
listening to music if I would be playing
the Spanish variation I'm sure I would
be listening to some classical music
Vivaldi Chopin Chopin I like yeah it's a
very cultured way to engage in here your
chess play but as stated at the
beginning of the show chess is not a
casual thing
okay listen to elevator music while
you're playing chess I need some art you
know if I would were to play the
Sicilian I would definitely listen to
some hard rock Black Sabbath Ozzy yeah
misfits that's not miss a bit funk but
but close Metallica and starving yeah
guitars lots of distortion yeah if I
would ever play the French then Nana it
must be just Justin Bieber or something
now you wouldn't listen
see that's why you don't play the French
you just don't like Justin Bieber's I'm
not getting you well yeah probably bad
fan none of them yeah I guess they're
not either yeah okay alright see so many
people so many people and we kindly
request from
Wow I don't know you're still putting
the pressure on me yeah let's let's go
with someone that's above 21 or 22 I'm
not gonna be more like there aren't
going to be many of those mm-hmm
scroll down a little bit okay maybe a
little further come on no one's above
2,100 here this guy just oh come on dude
yeah sure one of these two oh yeah
good luck all right I hope you play one
a six no don't do it you're not gonna
happen
noni noni okay again it's I'm still game
for suggestions okay I didn't mean do
you have pin you down to that you just
named buzz I am
okay ETR 9907 to to maybe we'll get you
next okay gonna give you a lesson about
petrov says I think the handle is I
can't be on Sarge ein as they are which
band for the dragon so I don't know if
yeah would you play which line do you go
you play they're not not sure if it if
you can is what it looked like from that
again yeah um and dragon so dragon could
be game well away because they're yet
they were riffing off of your Black
Sabbath +1 for Black Sabbath in Sicilian
okay thank you
only your very objective
pawns gathered in there okay I
understand that
could you play I don't I don't know what
you're talking about they're familiar
with the fit richer though and that's an
important question it's a very important
question
so you have Netflix do you watch I don't
know yeah I don't think there's anything
you do we can we get into a discussion
about pop culture here I don't know
that's that's the open question
basically I think it's a great show you
know that which is why you keep I keep
repeating it is the best to me you want
to evoke some sort of impassioned thing
about it and I just yeah great I feel
the pressure they're like coming in and
telling me I'm not doing my job I'm not
being exciting enough but guess how the
Richer was feeling they say yo you're
not being a real winner right now nobody
to work I didn't hear him ever say yo
you he mostly no I'm grunted it talking
to default people they could say yo I
mean I mean if the Witcher was to be
played in America and not in England I
don't even know if it's in England but
let's say english-speaking people hey
okay well yeah we're getting the know
Tony Chen was harassing us earlier he
sent Ben Simon in to you know threaten
us and we're just doing our best people
we hope you enjoy our humble little
presentation okay we hope and some yeah
the chat is reacting to our discussion
the book is good Netflix shows so so
mm-hmm Witcher 3 is some acronym which I
don't understand
I'm afraid to try wait do people
actually with some two people actually
understand what's going on in the show
it seems confusing well I don't know I
think you have to be uh how do you call
it an astute or
you know invested viewer I mean it
requires a little bit of attention
probably you had to choose between
playing one player or another which one
was yeah el raza door or ger Walt um
who's the first one that they're
referring to who is this el raza door I
know Geralt is the Witcher obviously yes
Geralt is a [ __ ] they must be referring
to the game which yeah all the Witcher
games are very good okay how do you like
the Wii Lopez dude we just talked about
how much he loves the real Lopez for
like five minutes okay
you mean versus all was okay you know to
go off on a small pet peeve of mine and
people forgotten how to spell losing I
mean people spell it with the double O
and it's just really confusing to me
you're saying yeah you're spelling
loosing people no losing is just one oh
that's it okay you can never hate on
someone for trying their best if I'm
doing that I'm sorry I don't think
that's what he's referring to but I'm
just gonna play with that all right I
agree with you just hating on people in
general is typically a bad idea yeah
don't hate people because they hate you
back I guess and then yeah and it's not
fun after that we want fun yeah I think
this will turned into the background
mate which is unfortunate
okay yeah all right they're talking
trash I want to find this person who's
handle starts with the G oh no I would
yeah we killed you killed me who's it
with
okay that's not I don't recall that I
think we can continue well I know I know
I remember this you remember yesterday
yeah
oh you this is for well someone using my
thing did it but I was there ah okay see
right there it was there and I sent it
to okay am I gonna get into it yeah no
that's fine all right
okay so we have time for one more is the
point yeah okay daddy's guy okay it's
you know you know who you want which one
you wanted well someone's promising us
rare magic in the petrov his name
'search that the g-hold I go down a
little bit
yeah and this guy oh yeah okay there you
go
all right bear magic in the paper
magician wonderful
our people is not at the board oh man
dude not cool not cool not cool at all I
think let's give him the 10-second
treatment okay uh calling yawns are ya
come on man you ask you ask us so there
you go all right come on you can do it
try to connect you can't yeah it looks
like maybe you're having a connection
problem oh it's hurt awesome
it's good to st. see things work f5
right am I wrong you're not wrong you're
not wrong Night Watch you six yeah
I'm just just checking with this Knight
f6 okay okay yeah 906 first right if it
takes check not have six Queen h4 and
then I'm threatening there understood
okay so I just need it to double-check
that
yeah actually going on barely
and I do want to ask what do you can't
ask right well that we have a question
for yes what do you what type of music
do you listen to while you play chess
okay then I don't believe you if you say
I'm not listening to music I'm just
concentrating on the game I'm highly
doubtful
that's what do you listen to exactly
that's the big question
ah my opponent is watching the stream
found Knight f6 unbelievable I guess I
could say that I think it's fine to say
that's unbelievable well I mean I I
remember your line though you gave Queen
h4 here yeah um I'm thinking about
options and options are good
okay Queen e2 is better ha I might
expect that one oh I am because yeah I'm
easily greedy I'm gonna take that it
could she come ha I have another one I
don't know I enjoyed this version of the
petrov where i'm up and yeah I got
seeing the rare magic but I think for
King the queen is usually the way to go
not he call ma he go yeah dubs okay we
got okay dubstep dubstep rock or electro
swing Timecop 1983 rare hailstorm I
don't know what that is does anyone
listen to Grace Jones that was an open
question for you Chad yeah we're gonna
try and do one more one little fast fast
fast fast
I guess we'll try another three
overrated okay try this person yeah okay
good luck good luck
hmm not so waiting and love well
I for one appreciate your patience
demeanor
let's see what we have
oh sure thing now that also thought okay
so let's make it as Hungarian as
possible there's nothing more hunger and
then the Budapest someone actually
requested that you played it so that is
fortuitous who create someone created
this yesterday okay it's attack attack
that pawn III that's a blunder that
horsey do you think whenever you play
chess
do you consider philosophical ideas
we're playing I found in all honesty in
perfect candor it is as the man in the
booth will tell you it takes the highest
level of focus and concentration from me
just stunts to hanging pieces to one
movers so no if I am that was a frank
answer if I am then I'm probably losing
Dennis if I'm like you know playing in a
some open tourney and starting to drift
off about a free will and and
what-have-you and and faileth fatalism
we're determinism right yeah they're not
I'm probably losing I'm gonna get gonna
hang a piece or something yeah that
could be a problem so I'm just stopping
wipe from castling not really worrying
that much and trying to inconvenience
that came over you one he does not look
like a happy king no that's a sad king
but kings are usually love bats that
even the sad King is not that sad yeah
that's true I don't know have I never
met a live King well nor right nor a
dead one
me either me is your queen going to
cheat you where she yeah this lady is
trying to harass that rook on h1 he does
not have a lot of support yep and you
know this is the Swiss cheese formation
ah the famous Swiss cheese formation yes
that's Castle let's put this king I did
not know that but Oh
oh my god taking pawns when greed is not
necessarily that bad in chess right let
me defend it rook and black is way
better yeah your king is safe safe like
Mike skiing is safe white King is a
little bit unconvinced you think he is
safe enough though I mean you can't
really get a Brooke on me follow you yes
but this night is kind of on a wild hunt
away from the other other people
we should have one I think I'm gonna
find a way not to lose my queen
so Bishop f1 I'll bring my queen to f5
and chill so I'm not entirely that
scared of the answer he won't panic yeah
I won't panic I mean after all my
masters never hang material well I'm not
sure that's a truth but I appreciate the
idea that's gonna I be for the idea as a
I'm attacking that Bishop taking control
of this D Phi square and I noticed that
the rook and queen is in line so if I
could get Bishop e7 that would be
perfection it exists in perfection yes
in form of yeah bishops on diagonals
those work or even could consider ideas
of d5
who gave this video at download yeah I
want to know that - it's probably Tony
Chen alright let's go for it
that's let's get aggressive
I think it makes sense
playing life we're just me and
aggressively
oh so this move would normally be good
except I see - Oh outside yes and
fortunately you can't take because I
take the whole set on the other side
okay so I'm gonna take here first and
then collect the full rook got it
well I did nothing but I feel some
strange sense of accomplishment mm-hmm
it's Chet alive they are alive yeah they
are alive alive and kicking
and we give a warning check check as a
warning and then I think this Huff that
night will come alive let's take that
guy okay
now whatever comes comes let's just
activate my rook I don't care about the
pieces you'll play Queen takes Knight
could go Queen e2 as well I'll attack
from there but this is just Pleasant in
83 you're getting really close to mating
especially as my rook enters the second
rank yeah I mean this is essentially
fighting me to here yeah
okay well chat I want to thank you for
joining us as soon as we wrap up this
game I believe we're gonna wrap up the
stream and main thing coming as the
dennis expected we're doing it
I think it's mate good game sir
lol good game - yeah I'll roast the door
and everybody else that played us thank
you for joining us in the chat thank you
for thank you for playing us have you
challenged and got a game in against us
okay I don't know the next time we're
doing this stream but we will let you
know and see you then
thank you very much
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you